the answer is if we use car dot methods
as the prototype for every new instance
then failed property lookups to those
instances will fall through to car dot
methods and thus every instance will
appear to have a dot move method even if
we don't manually copy them over on this
line that means we can get rid of this
line entirely we do still need to make
sure this local property gets added to
our new object since it's no longer in
line as part of an object literal we're
instead using this object to create
syntax as of this change we've arrived
at the completed prototypal pattern of
writing your class this is not to be
confused with the pseudo-classical
pattern which is coming up next